in this episode we're going to talk
about ng module and how to properly use
it to organize an angular application so
what's the purpose of an ng module in
the first place the answer is it helps
organize the complex relationship
between views such as components and
directives to data providers such as
services and guards it works by allowing
you to define all these relationships in
the Swingle file as opposed to doing it
individually and every component service
as was the case in early days of angular
2 now let's look inside an NG module and
see what these metadata terms actually
mean first we have declarations which is
where you would put any component
directive or pipe and then it'll be
privately available to that module if
you want it to be publicly available to
other modules then you'll need to add it
to the export section this concept is
similar to public and private functions
and object-oriented programming
components will be private by default
and become public if you add them to
exports other modules gain access to
exported components by importing that
module in their own metadata
so just to recap declarations imports
and exports define the relationship
between components and how they're
shared between different ng modules next
we have the bootstrap property which
defines a component that's used to
initially load your application by
default this will usually be the app
component which is created automatically
by the angular CLI the final property
you should be aware of is providers this
is where you register data providers
such as Services and guards that can be
injected into components within this
module the injectable class will be
available to any component in this
module as well as any module that
imports it
now let's look at some practical ways we
can use energy module to organize an
application in this example we have all
of our components and services in the
group app module that was created by
default as our app grows larger this
file is going to be more and more
cluttered and more and more hard to
maintain our goal is to refactor most of
our components and services to their own
modules with the exception of the app
component which we still want to
bootstrap from the root module overall
this will keep the logic in our app much
more organized now let's take a look at
the routing module that was created by
default by the angular CLI a routing
module should have no declarations it
may have providers in the form of guards
and it should always export the router
module we can add our contact list
component to the router and it will load
that component imperative way when the
route is activated which in this case is
just route URL depending on the
complexity of your app you may use
multiple routing modules for better
organization as well as lazy loading now
let's build a feature module to organize
everything related to contacts in our
app feature modules will consist mostly
of declarations and possibly a provider
but they should never export anything
their primary purpose is to organize
business logic related to a specific
feature we generate the module with the
angular CLI and copy everything related
to contacts over to it notice we're also
importing the common module that gives
us access to angular's most common
features such as NGS and 10g for now we
can go back to the route and delete
everything related to contacts then
import the contact module and add it to
the imports in the route if we had 20
different components related to contacts
you can see how this would greatly
improve the clutter and the file now
let's look at a shared module also
called widget modules they're almost
identical to future modules except that
they add all their declarations to the
exports as well so they can be
distributed to other module common use
cases include social media icons
Oh Dean spinners and other UI elements
similar to those let's generate the
module from the CLI then add the social
icons component to both the declarations
and the exports from there we can go
ahead and import it in both the root
module as well as the feature module we
created in the previous step now the
social icons component will be available
everywhere in the app the last type
we'll look at is a core or service
module it has no declarations and only
focuses on services for dependency
injection common providers to include
here would be an off service or a toast
message service anything that provides
data globally throughout the app in this
example we're extracting our off service
into the core module we generate it with
the CLI and copy over the auth service
to a new home we can also remove the
common module since we're all made
dealing with services here back in the
root we can go ahead and import the core
module and add it to the imports with
the others if we look over our app
launch well now we can see it's a lot
more organized we just have the one
declaration no providers the one
bootstrap component and just a handful
of modules to manage that covers the
main patterns you'll see with ng module
and angular applications in an upcoming
video I'll show you how to use the
router along with ng modules to lazy
load component that's it for this
episode if you found the video helpful
please like and subscribe and if you
want to support the channel consider
becoming a pro subscriber at angular
firebase comm for just a few bucks a
month you'll get access to your
exclusive content as well as free one on
one project consulting thanks for
watching and I'll see you next time
[Music]
you